it is legendary costume designer
Patricia fields
[Applause]
I am so happy to be sitting with you oh
Pat because you're a smarty pants and I
you know I that's a compliment no I'm
taking such brainy smart hard-working
everything that I love the best
[Applause]
coming from you that means so much we've
known each other and been on the scene
for a long time we have well you are a
legend and everybody loves you and I
wanted to play my favorite game here we
always do behind the scenes where we ask
people about their body of work because
having been you know on the scene myself
for my whole life I think a body of work
is something to recognize not just your
latest project what can you tell us
about this picture is actually in your
book
um what is the story behind this skirt
that was also in the opening sequence of
the show from the first episode until
the last
well the Greek story is that you know I
pulled it out of a little sail bin in a
showroom and knowing Sarah Jessica
Parker I thought this is perfect and
what do I have to lose it's five dollars
anyway so uh he has
she liked it Darren he was like he
didn't really understand it but he is
one of the best guys that I know I love
him but I said to him Darren
if this show is a hit
this little skirt will last forever it's
not trendy it's not from a year
it's just
classic
and so it became that and it did and it
did
you're so right all right The Devil
Wears Prada
there you are
with the I mean the most important
living actress of our times or any time
the great Merrell Street
how did you guys come up with Miranda
priestley's look
I always wanted to make her more
glamorous than many of the roles that
she had played and um I met with Meryl
and her um her grooming person and
um that's when they informed me that she
was going to do her hair white and the
white against the sophisticated
um fashionista that role that she was
playing I thought perfect but the
producers didn't no
they're guys they think white hair is
old lady they were giving me a hard time
and they wouldn't listen and I went and
I said Meryl you have to go there and
tell them you're wearing white hair
because I can't get through to them
she did and she wore white hair
I think sometimes people picture
something in their mind but when they
hear a pleading of a case and passion
with a vision behind it you can and it's
a good lesson like don't give up on your
vision sort of you know try to explain
it and don't just throw in the towel and
go well they won't let me like try
because you could probably win and get
through it
all right I I agree with you you have to
stand by what you believe in otherwise
no one's if you don't believe in
yourself no one's going to believe in
you yes yes absolutely
hot you've seen as the world a rainbow
you've made it a more beautiful place a
more joyful place a more artistic place
and your extraordinary book of which I
have been pouring through Page by page
is just incredible because it really is
a testament to the extraordinary life
that you've lived and I'm so glad now
that you can get it in this book Pat in
the city is available now everybody
check it out it is Joy from front to
back
and it's a meaningful story it's a
meaningful Journey you've been on so
thank you Pat thank you so much we'll be
right back everybody
[Music]